we've got a phone number that number is
two one nine two david p you can call
that number anytime and leave us
voicemail many people apparently listen
to or watch the show at two three four
five o'clock in the morning because
that's when a lot of people call i want
to play a really funny voicemail for you
this is about how i am a hypocrite on
the kneeling thing because if it was one
of my countrymen from argentina who was
kneeling I would lose my you know what
the crap would hit the fan so to speak
this is by the way I don't even know if
it makes sense to mention this but it
happens to be Troy York but he's doing
another one of these fake voices he
doesn't name this character but he's
trying to use a voice that is not Troy
York but it is Troy York and here's the
assertion he makes about my hypocrisy on
kneeling during the national anthem
David Beckmann
listening to show the stupid comments I
wanted to make first of all if Lionel
Messi Messi game because he kneeled out
in the Argentine game I'm sure you've
been very upset and too if you take down
all the Confederate statues then I think
there is also a case to take down
statues for Native American leaders who
work with the French and the British
Empire the French Empire and your
Spanish Empire such as - Cruz de Black
Hawk and Pontiac there are many statues
of Native Americans who who actually
slaughtered him and butchered and
attacked the American nation yes no one
talks about all right that's down those
statues yeah yeah
very good my Spanish Empire I don't know
what that's about listen I can assure
you that in the same way that I have no
problem with NFL players kneeling during
the American national anthem
I would have no problem if Leo Messi or
Messier as I think he referred to him
there Leonel Messier Argentinian soccer
player kneeled during the Argentinian
anthem I don't care about people
kneeling during any band oh you would be
outraged yeah we are ready what have I
said in the past that would suggest I'd
be outraged by that I mean I just don't
know I don't know where he's coming up
with this stuff what if he was to lie
down would you be outraged then do
whatever you want don't stay in the
locker room
kick the ball around it doesn't make a
difference you are free to express
yourself however you see fit if people
find it disrespectful and as a result
they don't want to buy tickets to watch
you play anymore then the market will
actually decide the the right talks
about supporting a free market and and
when they actually shouldn't like for
example health care which should not be
under the for-profit free-market
paradigm and then all of a sudden they
want to enforce social norms that seem
to border pretty closely on the
political correctness that they claim to
oppose and I just will never understand
it Leo Messi do whatever you want to do
during the Argentinian national anthem
or the Spanish national anthem he of
course plays for Barcelona or whatever
anthem you want I just don't care there
are bigger issues Puerto Rico's falling
apart they're trying to take away your
health care that's it that's it Troy or
I'm sorry whatever a character it is
that Troy is playing here I'm not
supposed to recognize that it's Troy
York on the bonus show today we will
talk about the Codfather what is more
Boston than the Codfather we will talk
about his new prison sentence also does
mood impact the effectiveness of flu
vaccines it seems it might and we will
talk to you about the story of Kings Kim
jong-nam
assassination david pakman.com slash
membership for the bonus show
patreon.com slash david pakman show will
also get you access to the bonus show